we're still in a pandemic of the
unvaccinated those are the words of
president joe biden speaking as the
tally of u.s covet deaths hit a
five-month high more than a thousand
people died in a single day and the new
wave is hitting the country
disproportionately the 10 states with
the most new cases are all in the south
in florida governor ron desantis has
banned schools from mandated masks
prompting a turf war with some counties
that have defied the governor and
ordered students to mask up but it's not
just florida in oregon louisiana and
arkansas there are more people in
intensive care than at any point in the
pandemic the so-called delta variant has
helped fuel a surge in hospital
admissions especially in states with low
vaccination rates and high skepticism
now some former vaccine skeptics are
voicing regret after falling ill
this is arkansas in the american south
mostly rural conservative and religious
[Music]
here the republicans are strong and the
vaccination rates are weak
healthcare workers prepare for another
day's battle at the university hospital
in the capital little rock
the enemy's name is delta
this nurse is putting in an extra shift
today because there's not enough staff
to care for the current wave of
critically ill patients
more and more pregnant women and
children are coming in
everybody has regret
it's heartbreaking every patient here
unvaccinated that's sick
regrets it
it is so hard to watch somebody in their
last week of their life last days of
their life
know that it's at their decision it's
that their decision they made to be in
this in this room in this bed and know
that they're probably not going to make
it
tate izai's family was dealt a heavy
personal loss
his wife christine
is at home traumatized by recent events
until just recently they were a happy
family
five children active
no fear of covid and no vaccinations
then delta hit christine was six months
pregnant as they both found themselves
fighting for their lives for weeks
i still thought she'd be okay but like i
said as things got worse and worse
i started really worrying
worrying about the baby
and then
at some point you know the baby just
didn't make it she was too low on oxygen
and
then i just worried about her after that
it's a contentious issue across the
united states one that is still being
fired up by the political right
by some media outlets by preachers
politicians
while infection rates soar
there will be no restrictions and no
mandates in the state of florida
[Applause]
the delta variant was nonsense then it
is nonsense now you will not wear masks
in this church you will not wear masks
in this church i'm telling you right now
do not get vaccinated do not get
vaccinated
many people feel unsettled
corey gordon does her bit to counter
that in her small pharmacy in little
rock
anyone can come here and get vaccinated
like everywhere else in the u.s
a vaccination is as easy to get as a
cough drop
more and more people show up every day
concerned about new variants
like these kids who just want to go to
school again and be carefree
or this mail carrier who just wants to
deliver packages
the e-zize family loss was painful
but they say if more people opt to
protect themselves and vaccinate perhaps
others could be spared similar grief
and my next guest knows at close hand
the health care situation in arkansas
i'd like to welcome from little rock
mark williams dean of the college of
public health at the university of
arkansas for medical services welcome to
the day sir it sounds like a grim
picture where you are
we heard some of the individual stories
in our report arkansas is one of the
country's coronavirus hot spots as you
well know
of the new admissions how many are
unvaccinated and how are they reacting
when they become sick
our new admissions are 90
are unvaccinated we do have some
breakthrough infections uh for people
that are vaccinated however
those patients are not nearly as sick as
those patients coming in who are
unvaccinated the patients that are
coming in who are unvaccinated are
extremely ill
and
um it's quite likely that their stay
in the hospital when they come in will
be longer
than
it was during our previous search with
the wild or uh original variant of the
virus
you're speaking very clearly sir but i'm
going to repeat it for emphasis you said
90 percent 90 or unvaccinated we heard
from the family in that report both
parents got sick and they lost their
baby now they're encouraging others to
get vaccinated frankly i've been hearing
stories like this for the past three to
four weeks
as far as you can tell are stories like
theirs encouraging more people to get
vaccinated
yes they are uh but not enough i will
say that before i uh make a longer
explanation
uh i believe in the last
month we have in arkansas had
approximately 300 000 people who have
gotten their first injection
however that's not nearly enough given
the infectiousness of the delta variant
still approximately two-thirds of the
state are not fully vaccinated and
that includes those children who are
under the age of 12 who of course cannot
be vaccinated
and so
um
we still have a lot of our population
that can become infected and uh
experience a very serious
disease during the first wave of this uh
pandemic we all remember the waves and
waves of images showing the the dire
situations in hospitals across the
united states how are hospitals coping
now in arkansas in terms of icu capacity
we are
at at the brink
of being
over capacity we have had some new beds
established
uh however what's more critical for us
than beds are the personnel needed
uh to um staff those beds as you can uh
well appreciate
the level of professionalism needed to
work in an intensive care unit
particularly with patients that are this
sick is very high and you can't you can
create new beds fairly easily
what's difficult is finding the
personnel to staff
those areas
let's look at one specific example here
texas governor greg abbott announced he
was infected with coronavirus earlier
this week as i'm sure you know although
he's fully vaccinated there are photos
of him socializing at republican events
maskless
how big a driver of infection
might events like that be and why is
delta significant
there they are
drivers any type of mass gathering like
that with a disease that is this
infectious
is a driver the delta variant of the
coronavirus is three times
as infectious as the uh
1918 flu vaccine and you can recall what
that did it was a huge number of people
worldwide that were infected and uh died
from that flu
the difference is now that we have a
preventable uh
situation we have a vaccine the vaccine
is extremely effective
in preventing serious disease and
hospitalization
and so um
[Music]
in some respects without being at all
political about it it is in my personal
opinion just irresponsible for a
political leader to
create a gathering like that would
potentially a large number of people who
are unvaccinated
in these times in this climate it's
difficult to say these sort of things
and not have people see it politically
but there it is mark williams dean of
the college of public health at the
university of arkansas for medical
services in little rock certainly
appreciate your time sir
well you're very welcome
you